[Musique]
on débat sur france 24 près de trois
mois après le début de l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie la finlande et
la suède décide maintenant de renoncer à
leur neutralité historique pour adhérer
à l'otan la suisse serait également en
train d'y réfléchir
l'otan pourrait même accélérer la
procédure d'adhésion mais la turquie s'y
opposent erdogan s'est dit résolu à
contrer cette demande d'adhésion
qualifiant la suède de nids de
terroristes joe biden a reçu à la maison
blanche aujourd'hui la première ministre
suédoise et le président finlandais le
président américain a affirmé que la
suède et la finlande remplissait tous
les critères pour entrer dans l'otan
quant à l'or ces deux pays vont-ils
effectivement rentré dans l'otan air
doan peut-il finalement y mettre son
veto
quelle est la réaction de la russie un
élargissement de l'otan renforcera tels
la sécurité en europe où y at-il au
contraire un risque d' escalade avec la
russie on en débat avec mes invités j'ai
le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés benoît
d'aboville bonsoir à vous tous et
bienvenue chercheur associé à la frs et
ancien ambassadeur auprès de l'otan en
face de vous et léna volochine et lennar
on ne connaît que vous sur ce plateau
bienvenue encore sur le débat
journaliste à france 24 correspondante
en russie et puis on vous suit toutes
les semaines tous les vendredis avec vue
de russie votre chronique justement qui
montre la propagande russe à la
télévision russe didier billion est avec
nos directeur adjoint de l'iris bonsoir
spécialiste de la turquie bienvenue à
vous également à washington nous avons
en duplex marie jourdain bonsoir
chercheuse invitée à l'atlantique quand
seuls your app center bienvenue à vous
également
joe biden je vous le disais a reçu à la
maison blanche la première ministre
suédoise magdalena anderson et le
président finlandais le président
américain soutient avec force et de
candidature vous avez vous allez
l'écouter ainsi d'ailleurs que la
première ministre suédoise
la suède et la finlande ont des solides
institutions démocratiques des armées
puissantes une économie forte et
transparente est aussi un important sens
moral de ce qui est juste
ils remplissent tous les critères de
l'otan
l'agression à grande échelle de la
russie contre un voisin souverain et
démocratique était un moment décisif
pour la suède et mon gouvernement est
arrivé à la conclusion que la sécurité
du peuple suédois sera mieux protégé au
sein de l'alliance de l'otan nous
bénéficions d'un très large soutien au
sein de parlement suédois est avec la
suède et la finlande ont tant que membre
l'otan sera également plus forte
est-ce que c'est effectivement la menace
poutinienne qui a poussé on peut le dire
la finlande et la suède dans les bras de
l'otan oui est-ce qu'on peut le
présenter comme ça lui l'invasion de
l'ukraine a fait basculer les opinions
danser mais ces deux pays mais
là la suède et la finlande avait déjà
une coopération militaire très très
développée avec l'otan ainsi qu'avec les
autres avec les pays baltes et aucune
coopération nordique très efficace donc
moi ça ne leur suffit plus parce qu'ils
veulent la garantie d'articles 5 c'est à
dire la garantie de la solidarité alors
c'est pas une solidarité automatique
comme vous le savez mais c'est tout de
même en termes de dissuasion d'une
attaque c'est quand même fondamental
il n'y aura pas d'avenir pacifique avec
la russie a affirmé la première ministre
finlandaise c'est historique pour vous
qui connaissez bien l'otan son
fonctionnement écoutez
les nous avons eu les précédents
élargissements
il ya toujours eu des attentes et des
impatiences ya jamais eu de blocage et
je pense pas que erdogan puisse bloquer
envers venir mais sur l'intention sur ce
cette sortie de la neutralité
les d'ores et déjà les les finlandais
les suédois participer par exemple des
opérations militaires avec les européens
en afrique c'était une autre était
relatif qui avait évolué qui a évolué
elle était de nature différente pour les
pour les suédoises c'est identitaire ça
fait partie de leur histoire pour les
finlandais s'étaient quelques chutes et
un compromis pour vivre avec un voisin
dangereux au lendemain de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
c'est donc tout de même renoncé à leur
identité les suisses d'ailleurs alors
emboîté vous avez ces pays évolué après
tout la suisse par exemple à abandonner
le secret bancaire qui était parti de
son décès notre identité alors justement
marie journal puisque vous êtes avec
nous à washington joe biden a reçu
aujourd'hui donc la première ministre
suédoise magdalena anderson le président
fallon des on les a vus à l'image
c'était il ya il ya un petit instant il
soutient avec force et deux candidatures
joe biden pourquoi est ce qui les pousse
véritablement certains disent que les
états unis auraient même fait pression
alors juste avant de répondre je
rappeler un point qui est important pour
les suédois et les finlandais ils ne
parlent pas ton de neutralité à
l'origine que de non alignement ou de
non alliance et c'est ça qui a changé et
qui au moment du déclenchement de la
guerre par par la réussir en ukraine
il ya vraiment l'idée que ce qu'on
pensait
une fois landais qui pensaient pouvoir
prévoir en fait les mouvements russes
ont été extrêmement surpris et c'est
pour ça qu'il se tourne aussi vers
l'otan puisqu'ils ne sont plus ce
concert plus en mesure de prévoir sur le
soutien américain
très clair c'est un soutien qui est
complètement partagé en europe et comme
aux états unis comme au canada
puisque comme comme ce qui a été dit
précédemment la coopération avec ces
pays est déjà extrêmement approfondie en
termes d'interopérabilité en termes
d'exercices communs çà çà çà n logique
puisque ces armes et se connaissent
entre elles ça renforce la sécurité dans
la zone baltique notamment donc c'est
une logique après jamais les américains
on dit il faut absolument que la suède
et la finlande ne rejoigne cela c'est un
débat qui était qu est l attente depuis
depuis plusieurs années qui n'avançait
pas forcément parce que c'est vraiment
les opinions publiques locales qui ont
fait changer la donne et l'appréciation
de la sécurité régionale qui qui change
pour ces pays là et des logiques les
états unis d accueil avec enthousiasme
mais mais ils ont plutôt attendu le pas
fin des se doit didier lyonnais qui
n'est pas enthousiaste c'est le
président r doha le président turc qui
lui alors s'opposent depuis la semaine
dernière cette adhésion il est revenu à
la charge d'ailleurs on va l'écouter le
président turc
nous sommes résolus à maintenir notre
position nous avons informé nos amis que
nous dirons non à la finlande et à la
suède qui veulent rejoindre l'otan et
nous persisterons dans cette voie
cette suède 17 finlande sont les pays
qui hébergent les terroristes chez eux
le pkk est dit greg pg nous sommes très
préoccupés par ces deux pays surtout par
la suède qui a un foyer de terreur un
nid absolue de terroristes
10 millions à ce que c'est il fait de la
politique intérieure la le président r
doan est-ce qu'il bluffe os
qu'effectivement il perçoit ces pays
comme hébergeant le pkk les kurdes
on a du mal à comprendre il ya une
réalité de toute façon il ya eu là une
contradiction majeure
puisque je rappelle que le pkk est
considéré comme une organisation
terroriste est qualifié comme tel bien
évidemment par la turquie mais aussi par
les pays membres de l'union européenne
par les états unis et effectivement nous
savons qu'il ya des dirigeants du pkk
qui se trouve en suède et en finlande
entre autres qu'il y en a aussi à paris
donc de la qualifier il vise en
particulier la recette d'ailleurs mais
va parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
l'actualité parce que ces deux pays
demandent leur adhésion à l'otan est que
monsieur ardoines pense qu'il peut se
servir de ce dossier comme d'un moyen de
pression je pense qu'il ya une partie de
bluff il ya une il essaye de faire
monter les enchères
c'est un jeu extrêmement dangereux mais
nous sommes habitués avec monsieur
erdogan qui le fasse monter les enchères
c'est toujours cette difficulté avec les
turcs quand il ya un enjeu politique
diplomatique internationale ils tendent
l'accord tant de l'accord temps l'accord
jusqu'au dernier moment puis au dernier
moment on trouve un accord j'espère que
ce sera encore le cas donc c'est anne
opportuniste là lorsqu'il dit qu il eut
il instrumentalise une situation mais
surtout ne sous-estimons pas
l'importance de la lutte contre le pkk
du point de vue de la turquie et pas
seulement du point de vue de monsieur
ardoines sachez bien que sur ce dossier
l'immense majorité des partis qui sont
représentés au parlement turc sont sur
la même longueur d'onde aujourd'hui à
l'exception d'un qui est le parti
démocratique des peuples qu'est le parti
kurde est évidemment il n'est pas sur la
même longueur d'onde mais vous parlez
d'instrumentalisation
non david hess cardo one peut empêcher
véritablement cette adhésion d'abord je
crois qu'il faut acheter il ya également
il ya également un contentieux avec les
etats-unis qui ont abrité goulaine lors
du la tentative de coup d'état et à ce
moment là il faut se souvenir que c'est
poutine qui a averti
et les colonnes et toujours aux états
unis et les états unis refuse de
l'extrader et goulaine c'est pour
erdogan c'est un islamiste qui l'a
trahie puisqu'il était saoul alors
maintenant est resté dans l'otan erdogan
malgré tout ça ah oui mais bon et mais
parce que m parce que ère du web et est
un très très bon
effectivement la turquie est monté les
tentes mais la turquie la turquie est à
une diplomatie à plumes en remarquable
quelquefois
mécontents paris avec la grèce en
méditerranée mais eux
ils ont toujours ils ont toujours fait
des négociations de bazar jusqu'au
dernier moment et je cours je pense
qu'actuellement ce qu'il veut c'est à la
fois réglé le problème goulaine et
régler le problème des f-35 puisque les
etats-unis les ont bloqués au moment où
il achetait et ds des missiles anti
missiles russes mais
pardonnez moi mais juste ce dont le
fonctionnement de l'otan est bien
d'accord ce pays peuvent bloquer
celles
du consensus je crois que ça serait
catastrophique
que dans l'émotion ukrainienne on
abandonne ce principe du consensus qui
est fondamental à l'otan et nous nous
mêmes nous l'avons beaucoup beaucoup
défendu et nous continuerons de le
défendre tf1 le convaincre j'imagine
elena volochine la russie a bien sûr
réagi vladimir poutine a affirmé que la
fin de la neutralité de son voisin
serait une erreur mais pas tout à fait
une menace on va l'écouter le président
russe c'était le 16 mai lundi
en finlande
ed je voudrais vous informer chers
collègues que la russie n'a aucun
problème avec ces états comment
l'élargissement de l'otan à ces pays ne
constitue pas une menace immédiate pour
nous pour la russie
mais le déploiement d'infrastructures
militaires sur les territoires de ces
pays entraînera bien sûr qu'une réponse
donc il fait une distinction là ok si
vous entrez dans l'otan mais pas
question d'y avoir des militaires donc
de l'otan fin bref subtil oui la lumière
poutine quel est le message alors je sa
réaction était effectivement plus mesuré
que celle que l'on aurait pu attendre
lorsqu'on sait qu'il a lancé la guerre
en ukraine précédent de 7,7 invasion a
suivi des exigences sans précédent vis à
vis de washington et de l'otan qui était
que l'otan retire complètement des
militaristes complètement retire ses
troupes des pays qui ont intégré
l'alliance depuis 1997 que l'ukraine
s'engage à la neutralité et cetera et
cetera donc on pourrait s'attendre qu'à
l'heure où deux pays décident d'intégrer
l'otan est de doubler la frontière de
l'otan avec la russie qu'il est une
réaction beaucoup beaucoup plus forte la
lecture que j'en fais c'est que bon
d'abord dernièrement il a tendance à ne
pas réagir comme on s'attendrait à ce
qu'ils réagissent et puis ensuite tout
simplement il est tellement embourbé il
est tellement embêter avec l'histoire
ukrainienne que clairement ce n'est pas
sa priorité clairement aussi pour une
fois il ya une once de sincérité dans ce
qu'il dit à savoir que il sait que la
suède et la finlande n'ont aucunement
l'intention d'attaquer la russie et
d'avoir le dans cela en cela le soutien
de l'otan en revanche ce qu'il aurait pu
dire effectivement c'est que ce sont des
nids de nazis qu'ils sont
instrumentalisés une fois de plus par
les états unis pour faire la queue que
l'otan ait cette pieuvre qui avant ses
tentacules vers la réussite c'est
toujours cette vision un peu fantasmé
quillan qui en présentent alors qu'on
sait que les états sont souverains dans
leur demande d'adhésion à l'otan donc
effectivement voilà moi je pense que en
fait cette réaction cela n'en est pas
uni la ville a fait l'exercice il a fait
son devoir voilà mais c'est clairement
pas une priorité aujourd'hui il entend
cas il a annoncé la fin des exportations
d'électricité russe enfin huit ans mais
ça c'est n'est donc on est un peu dans
les représailles en même temps oui mais
n'oublions pas que la finlande la suède
n'accepteront pas des armes nucléaires
sur leur sol de même qu'il ya d'autres
pays de l'otan comme la norvège ou le
danemark ils ont d'ailleurs bien rappelé
que c'était défensif ils ont eu un
discours justement histoire d'apaiser la
réaction russe c'est cela le fait qu'il
est le fait qu'il qu'il entame dès
qu'ils montrent un peu les muscles qu'il
y a aussi des témoignages comme quoi il
y aurait des lance-missiles kiki qui
vont un peu dans la région que ça se
militarise qu'il y ait plus de contrôle
aux frontières et c'est bon tout ça
c'est évidemment c'est normal ça
participe de cette demain tu fais de
maintenir cette confrontation mais il
n'a pas intérêt à ce que je veux dire
par là c'est qu'il n'a pas intérêt à
faire monter la confrontation à l'heure
où il ne peut absolument pas l'assumer
militairement quant à la finlande jeu
d'un point de vue russe en tout cas je
ne pense pas que dans cette velléité de
reconstruction de l' empire russe qu'il
y a dans tout ce discours idéologique y
compris celui qui a précisé précédé
l'invasion de l'ukraine il y est eu à un
moment donné la vérité d'un bailleur la
finlande bien que la finlande a fait
partie il faut le rappeler de l' empire
jusqu'en 1917 ce qui fait que dans la
construction purement idéologique de
vladimir poutine les finlandais aurait
raison de se méfier de la russie mais
concrètement il n'a pas aujourd'hui
clairement les moyens de ses ambitions
ce qui fait qu'en fait c'est presque un
non sujet d'un point de vue comme de
l'ojd a rejeté dans la zone les gardes
kaliningrad
au milieu marie jourdain est ce qu'on
parle je sais pas ce qu'on a parlé
aujourd'hui à washington de la menace
russe justement avec cette adhésion de
la finlande et de la suède en sachant qu
effectivement ça va multiplier enfin ça
va agrandir la frontière entre la russie
et l'otan est ce qu'on parle de cette
menace russe à washington possible
alors là la préoccupation en réalité
actuelle en termes de sécurité elle
n'est pas tant sur l'adhésion une fois
effective de la suède et de la finlande
dans l'otan mais de la période en fait
de transition qui commence maintenant
jusqu'au processus en fait de
ratification de l'ensemble des états
membres de l'otan qui peut prendre
plusieurs mois puisque ça passant par
les parlements
des états membres en grande majorité et
c'est cette période en fait d'entre deux
où la suède et en finlande ne sont pas
dans l'otan mais ils veulent la
rejoindre et que c'est le moment en fait
pour la réussite de potentiellement
jouer jouer d avancer ses pions et c'est
pour ça notamment qu'il ya énormément de
discussions qui sont en cours que ce
soit au niveau bilatéral
avec d'autres états européens avec les
états unis pour en fait gérer cette
période
assez tendue pour convaincre pour
s'assurer qu'il n'y aura pas de
l'agression russe alors on peut penser
notamment des menaces plutôt hybride
d'attac cyber et c est à cet égard il
est assez remarquable de voir parce que
les britanniques mais aussi d'autres
membres de l'alliance comme l'islande la
norvège danemark ont déjà assuré que la
suède et la finlande qu'ils seront là au
niveau 2 en termes de solidarité tout
comme la france au titre de l'article 40
de 7 du traité de l'union européenne qui
qui oblige pas qui prévoit une
assistance mutuelle en cas d'agression
puisque la suède et la finlande sont
membres de l'union européenne de
notables ville justement pour rebondir
sur ce que vient de dire
marie jourdain est ce qu'un autre temps
l'otan qui a grandi sa frontière avec la
russie est ce que ça représente
effectivement une garantie de paix
supplémentaires en europe ou au
contraire est-ce que c'est un risque
d'escaladé à la limite peut être un
risque de déstabilisation
donc je prends pas en revanche c'est
croyez franchement très important dans
la configuration interne de l'otan
puisque c'est quelque chose le centre de
gravité de l'otan vont se déplacer vers
le flanc est alors que jusqu'à présent
on les français par exemple les italiens
pensaient plutôt au flanc sud mais
je risque d'escaladé avec la russie non
au monde
je ne pense pas que les chinois vous
souvenez que c'était ça la met autant
autant outin c'était que l'ukraine entre
dans le temps en temps ce qui a été dit
sur la manière dont poutine percevait
l'occidentalisation de l'ukraine est un
vrai problème y compris d'ailleurs pour
une partie de l'opinion russe autant
franchement la suède et la finlande ce
n'est pas perçu comme une menace par par
les russes même et je moi je pense que
ça va ça va changer le concept
stratégique de l'otan qui doit être
adopté en juin prochain au sommet de
madrid
en novembre dernier le secrétaire
général avait fait un certain nombre de
propositions qui apparaissent
complètement hors sol aujourd'hui
c'était la bureaucratisation de l'otan
mondialisation du rôle de l'otan rapport
soutient aux américains vis-à-vis de la
confrontation avec la chine accède à
aujourd'hui
il ya un retour sur les fondements
historiques de l'otan c'est-à-dire la
défense de l'europe et alors cela dit ça
ne veut pas dire que aux états unis on
oublie la chine je crois que c'est très
important de ne pas faire l'erreur de
penser que l'activité actuelle de baden
sur 10 à vis de l'opinion publique il a
des élections bientôt
sur sur l'ukraine veut dire qu'il a bu
il abandonne la priorité fondamentale de
la chine est-ce que c'est pas la
contradiction justement dit beyoncé
autant face à la russie est ce que ce
parapluie américain est véritablement
fiable et qu'est-ce qui sera fiable tout
le temps avec byden avec ses successeurs
peut pas dire qu'il sera fiable tout le
temps mais ce qui est très important la
paix en europe c'est qu'on voit une
double logique qui n'est pas totalement
antagonique à ce stade mais qui pourrait
le devenir on voit bien que la position
des états unis à l'égard de la russie à
propos de ce conflit est une position
dure c'est à dire qu'ils veulent
absolument à faiblir au maximum le cren
je ne suis pas certain que ce soit
exactement la position de l'ensemble des
membres de l'otan mais par ailleurs
membre de l'union européenne
ainsi par exemple cela a été évoqué tout
à l'heure le fait que le président
macron est évoqué qu'en cas d'agression
de la suède de la finlande la france se
situerait bien évidemment à leurs côtés
au nom de l'article 47 du traité de
lisbonne est très important c'est à dire
que l'otan n'est pas forcément
unanimement derrière la position la plus
radicale qui est aujourd'hui portée est
incarnée par les états unis mais quel
état elle exactement cette position en
termes de réponse c'est à dire celle
celle des américains zelda c'est à dire
que toutes les déclarations de
l'administration by donn é du président
bailon vont tous dans le même sens il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui de volonté de
négocier quoi que ce soit alors vous me
direz pour négocier il faut a minima un
interlocuteur et que poutine n'est pas
le plus facile d'entre eux ça c'est une
évidence mais pour autant je pense que
par exemple président macron pour sa
part continué c'est lui et maintenant
reprocher depuis quelques jours il y a
une petite musique en viande et riz oui
mais continue à discuter avec poutine ça
sert à quoi il faut continuer à discuter
avec poutine même si la marge de
manoeuvre est extrêmement étroite alors
que les etats unis eux sont pour une
position dure pour mettre à genoux la
russie ce que je pense personne n'a
véritablement intéressés c'est un débat
odeurs aux états unis qui remonte aux
années 50 entre
contenir l'expansion soviétique ou bien
essayer de casser l'urss est
actuellement le secrétaire à la défense
austin
a laissé entendre qu'il fallait profiter
de l'occasion pour affaiblir
la russie de telle sorte qu'il n'y ait
plus de risques d'agression et c'est ça
c'est quelque chose que à mon avis la
majorité des pays de l'otan ne partage
pas parce que ça comporte un risque d'
escalade marais jourdain vous êtes
d'accord joue frères agir juste après il
y en a
c'est en effet un vrai débat ici aux
etats-unis et qui est lié à la chine en
réalité puisque il yal'idée il faut
avoir en tête que baye donne était
vice-président en 2014 quand il ya
l'agression russe en crimée donc des
gens en ukraine qui a contraint en fait
le pivot vers l'asie où l'un d'eux
pacifique des états unis en les ramenant
de nouveau en europe parallèlement à
des shows au moyen-orient et du coup il
ya en effet dans les cercles de
réflexion à washington l'idée que c'est
le moment d'affaiblir durablement
puisque sinon dans dix ans on en remet
une couche et donc c'est un débat qui
est qui est présent il ya des réflexions
aussi sûr qu'elle est en effet
l'objectif final recherché en revanche
ce qui me paraît vraiment important de
souligner ici et qui apparaît dans les
débats c'est que c'est une guerre qui
est menée par le cren avec certes de
soutien des états unis et de nombreux
pays européens mais c'est bien lui crème
qui sera la seule à décider quels termes
de la négociation elle veut mettre à la
table au final et quelles garanties de
sécurité elle va vouloir ensuite exigé
des de ses partenaires quelle forme cela
pourrait prendre mais c'est important ce
n'est pas les états unis ou la france
qui négocie au nom de l'ukraine c'est
bien l'ukraine le jour où le rapport de
forces
le permettra entre la russie et
l'ukraine mais qui n est définitivement
un débat qui est en cours aux états unis
qui n'est pas forcément en tranches et
elena vue de russie justement est ce que
il ya un encerclement à ce que poutine
se sentiraient aujourd'hui piégés ou
encerclé par l'otan est ce que ou pas
est-ce que ça le pousserait justement à
la négociation parce que comme disent
les américains il faut l'affaiblir
probablement pour négocier derrière ou
pas alors tout est dans le fait de
savoir quelle est la part de mythe ou de
conviction sincère paranoïaque du fait
que l'otan voudrait attaquer la russie
puisque évidemment dans la construction
discursive russe l'otan c'est la menace
de toujours et c'est finalement on a
fait la guerre pour avoir la paix on
attaque les premiers pour éviter d'être
attaquée c'est ça finalement que 10
bladimir poutine et que fait vladimir
poutine parce que du point de vue du
discours russe on se défend on n'attaque
pas on n'a pas agressé on entend même
aujourd'hui la télévision russe des gens
dire voilà il faut maintenant qu'on
agresse il faut qu'on attaque l'ukraine
il faut qu'on en finisse parce que comme
s'il ne l'avait pas encore attaqué donc
on est dans un mythe absolu de ce côté
là ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
lorsqu'on pose la question cette
question de savoir est ce que le fait
que et on va alors que l'otan va
s'élargir que deux nouveaux pays où elle
intègre est ce que cela va mener à la
paix ou à la confrontation c'est quelque
part prêter foi à ce mythe parce qu'on
partirait du principe que vladimir
poutine est dans la réaction est donc
dans la défensive par rapport à quelque
chose qui serait offensif vis-à-vis de
lui c'est perdre de vue le fait que
vladimir poutine est à l'initiative
vous parliez tout à l'heure de contenir
l'expansion soviétique aujourd'hui on
est dans cette même logique vladimir
poutine se place dans la directe lignée
de sept de ses stratégies de cette
politique de cet impérialisme qui est
lui d'étendre son territoire et c'est
pour ça aujourd'hui qu'il présente
l'ukraine comme un état qui n'existe pas
qui doit être un seul qui est un ce qui
ne doit pas être qui est déjà de fait
selon lui un seul pays avec la russie et
que finalement c'est une erreur de
l'histoire du fait qu'il y ait un état
voisin qui s'appellerait l'ukraine donc
aujourd'hui les dans cette stratégie
l'apurement impérialiste est pour comme
il ne peut pas dire aujourd'hui au 21ème
siècle
étant mon territoire sur les frontières
de l'empiré en menant une guerre ça ne
colle pas à la rationalité du droit
international qui dit on ne fait pas
aujourd'hui une guerre pour conquérir
des territoires et bien le discours est
de dire je suis dans la défense
vis-à-vis de l'otan qui s'étend et donc
finalement posé cette question là est-ce
qu'on provoque l'admirent poutine est ce
que c'est à cause de nous est ce que
c'est parce que on intègre de nouveaux
pays et l'otan qu'il va réagir pour moi
en tout cas d'un point de vue
intellectuel c'est biaisé mais il
n'oublie n'oublions pas n'oublions est
normal que quand poutine parle de l'otan
il pense états unis c'est normal non ces
résultats au début non mais attention au
début de la crise il attendait m'a donné
moi me donnez vous y aurez bien d'accord
que le boss au sein de l'otan ce sont
les états unis il ya trente membres ce
pas seulement un pas seulement ils
peuvent pas tout faire et on l'a vu avec
la crise irakienne
il a favor l'otan n'est pas intervenu en
irak parce que ce n'est pas le sujet
n'est pas le sujet
nous sommes opposés mais ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que ça reste en
décembre 10 décembre dans l'organisation
on a commencé quand la crise a commencé
qu est ce qu a fait poutine il envoyait
un projet de traité dans lequel il il a
marginalisé et l'union européenne qu'ils
détestent et
lé et les autres il s'adressait aux
états unis et au des hôtes d'ailleurs au
départ il ya eu un dialogue avec les
états unis je me souviens on irait à
genève à l'époque fans dialogue
effectivement s'est terminée par une
guerre quelques mois après donc que
personne n'a vu didier billion est ce
que c'est encore une fois cette logique
de bloc parce qu'on veut on revient dans
une logique de bloc occidental face à la
russie c'est quand même ça qui se
dessine aujourd'hui est ce que c'est une
bonne logique on sait que les pays
émergents ont par exemple ya beaucoup de
d'autres pays dans le monde qui se
disent non alignés qui n'aime pas ce ce
bloc occidental est ce que c'est ça qui
va tout de même garantir la paix en
europe eur22 deux éléments de réflexion
premièrement cette logique de blocs
allait malheureusement servi alimenté
par l'agression russe je suis pour ma
part deux éléments de réflexion
totalement contre c'est logique de blocs
qui était voulu par l'administration by
donne avant même le 24 février
rappelez-vous que monsieur by john
voulait construire le blog des
démocraties
entraîné donc ce qu'il appelle le monde
occidental et times wire
contre la russie est évidemment contre
la chine je pense que la france par
exemple et l'union européenne n'ont pas
totalement les mêmes intérêts que la
russie que là que les états unis à
l'égard de la russie et à l'égard de la
chine donc là nous sommes dans une
situation très compliquée parce que
évidemment la situation actuelle rend
difficilement audible ceux qui sont
contre la logique de bloc parce que
c'est la guerre et parce que se
cristallisent ces deux blocs mais je
pense qu'il faut faire preuve de courage
savoir prendre du recul c'est infiniment
compliqué parce qu'il y à une guerre il
y a des mort il ya des bombardements
mais pour autant la politique ne se fait
pas sous le coup de l'émotion je suis
désolé de le dire et donc il faut que
nous sachions aussi avoir le courage
collectivement de prendre le recul
nécessaire pour éviter de tomber dans
ces surenchères et c'est logique de
blocs qui ont été déclenchées par
poutine mais qui sont aujourd'hui
alimenté par celui qui dirige l'otan
c'est à dire les états donc vous trouvez
que les états unis font de la surenchère
vis la maman marie jourdan vous verrez
vous rebondir peut-être cette impression
que les états unis font de la surenchère
face à la russie est ce qu'on est un peu
dans une séquence émotion ou est-ce que
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui va vraiment
structurer durablement l' architecture
de la sécurité en europe autour donc
d'une logique de blocs états unis autant
d'un côté et russie de l'autre
alors il ya une véritable émotion mais
je dirais qu'elle est plus importante en
europe qu'aux états unis en réalité on a
vu des décisions majeures de
renversement de politique étrangère en
allemagne au danemark
désormais donc en suède et en finlande
beaucoup plus finalement que qu'aux
états unis donc ce serait serait déjà
mon premier point je rejoins ce qui été
dit sur la logique de rassembler les
démocraties ce que j'ai trouvé
remarquable depuis depuis février dans
la stratégie des états unis c'est que
certes on a eu une revitalisation de
l'otan dans son rôle premier de la
défense collective de l'europe avec une
pointe intention de ne pas souhaiter que
l'otan ne soutiennent pas directement
l'ukraine mais uniquement les états ce
qu'est ce qui est quand même important
mais docile associer les autres pays
n'ont autant d'autres zones en indo
pacifique notamment avec le japon la
corée du sud l'australie la nouvelle
zélande qui ont pris qui sont donc des
démocraties et qui ont pris des
sanctions
beaucoup plus forte que ce qui avait été
le cas en 2014 et c'est davantage en
fait dans cette logique là que je vois
une confrontation de bloc après ce qu
est ce qui est vraiment important pour
les états unis s'étaient que depuis
jusqu'au déclenchement de la guerre et
de la même jeu jusqu'à la fin jusqu'au
tournant de l'année 2021 2022 on avait
une vraie volonté des états unis de se
concentrer donc sur la chine est d'avoir
avec la russie une relation qui se
qualifié de stable et prévisible et
c'était dans cette perspective là qu'ils
avaient ré engager un dialogue de sur la
stabilité stratégique avec d une vraie
volonté non pas de repartir à zéro mais
d'avancé c'était possible et de limiter
et c'est très important de redire que
c'est bien vladimir poutine qui est
responsable de la situation aujourd'hui
est que en effet les etats-unis ont
réagi et mais en très forte coordination
avec les européens et je serai un peu
peut-être en plus en désaccord avec avec
mes collègues ici autour de la table
puisque jamais on n'a été aussi proche
et alignés et en concertation que quand
tout le monde est là volochine un mot
peut-être sur les ukrainiens sur le
terrain vous qui connaissez bien le
terrain le don de basse quelle
perception ont-ils de cette cet entre et
finalement des de la finlande et de la
suède au sein de l'otan de cette logique
de blocs pour parler des ukrainiens
justement pas juste pour nous écarter un
peu la finlande et la suède voudrais
rebondir sur cette question de l'émotion
que j'entends de plus en plus ces
derniers jours ces dernières semaines
autour de la guerre en ukraine qu il
faut arrêter les émotions qu'il faut
être pragmatique il ne faut pas être
dans une confrontation avec la russie
etc
je trouve qu'il ya une banalisation
aujourd'hui de ce qui se passe de la
guerre en ukraine comme quelque chose de
finalement bon ça existe il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose mais il faut pas non
plus exagérer faire de la surenchère etc
etc je suis désolée la situation est
dramatique terrible et il ce qu'il faut
comprendre aujourd'hui c'est que ce
n'est pas seulement une guerre en
ukraine c'est que le régime qu'il ya
aujourd'hui en russie et j'en reviens
c'est à dire que j ai passé dix ans et
j'entendais toujours en étant de
l'intérieur ces discours de l'extérieur
comme quoi il ne faut pas humilier la
russie il ne faut pas rabaisser la
russie etc
le premier aujourd'hui qui
qui qui qui peut vous le disais qu'il
provoque la situation mais aujourd'hui
aussi qui provoque le fait que dans son
propre pays les gens n'ont aucune
liberté n'ont aucune capacité de se
développer celui qui aujourd'hui a fait
prisonnier son peuple en quelque sorte
de la situation s'est aussi place d'hier
poutine et donc on avait beaucoup de mal
de l'extérieur entendre ce discours
comme quoi il ne faut pas rabaisser la
russie comme quoi la russie ça c'est
amalgamer à bladimir poussines et que si
l'on critique ou coloration le rapport
de force avec vladimir poutine se serait
rabaissé la russie les russes et c'est
là où je veux en venir c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les seuls finalement qui
assume ce rapport de force avec la
dîmière poutine ce sont les états unis
parce que et ils ont ils je pense qu'ils
sont dans cette position de dire que si
on n'arrête pas bladimir poutine ce ne
sera pas seulement aujourd'hui la guerre
en ukraine il est je pense et je suis
intimement convaincu qu'il s'est posé la
question autour de vladimir poutine
d'employés ou non l'armé nucléaire de
provoquer ou non une troisième guerre
mondiale on était dans une confrontation
comme dans une montée de la
confrontation sans précédent et ce qui
fait aujourd'hui qu'il est freinée qu'il
ait stoppé c'est parce que militairement
il en train de perdre du terrain mais
s'il s'il pouvait gagner du terrain
militairement parce que les états unis
n'aurait pas envoyé les armes qu'ils ont
envoyés en ukraine n'auraient pas à
assumer ce rapport de force aujourd'hui
ils seraient en train de gagner la
guerre et les prochains a menacé ce ne
serait pas les ukrainiens se serait
peut-être les moldaves les géorgiens
boire nous les européens donc en fait
voilà cette situation aujourd'hui il y a
un rapport de forces est évidemment de
l'autre côté la question n'est pas de
savoir est ce qu'on fait monter la
confrontation ou pas c'est ce qu'on est
capable de résister finalement qu'elle
vous sortez pas d'aboyer là je verrai je
crois good correspondante de
l'interlocuteur à washington j'en avais
la question des sanctions et c'est
extrêmement important parce qu'il n'y a
jamais eu autant d'unanimité derrière
les sanctions contre la russie on n'a
jamais opéré des sanctions aussi
importante fête nombreux pays émergents
ne les ont pas voté oui mais
souvenez-vous qu'en 2014 les solutions
étaient continue la grève le l'invasion
du donbass tu sanction était beaucoup
plus faible aujourd'hui vous avez d'un
côté la moitié de la population mondiale
avec la chine l'inde etc qui ne
soutiennent pas ils veulent pas prendre
parti mais vous avez des sanctions qui
ont un effet qui vont notamment sur le
plan technologique qui vont
véritablement rabaisser les le potentiel
de la russie pendant très longtemps moi
je ne pense pas que des sanctions vont
disparaître très rapidement parce que
les états unis ne voudront pas en
revanche en europe les sanctions au delà
de au delà de la fin de l'année ou peut
être
ça pèse sur le quotidien des européens
je pense que là on aura un vrai débat
noble transatlantique sur la durée des
sanctions est l'objectif des sanctions
est ce que c'est pour en finir avec la
russie comme puissance ou bien est ce
que c'est pour peser sur
la rai la décision
la décision en ukraine ça sera sur le
terrain vous avez parfaitement raison
c'est après tout ce sont les nations les
ukrainiens qui se battent actuellement
donc c'est ça sera fonction de l'
équilibre qui sera atteint sur le tout
sur le thème est ce qu'il y aura une
défaite des russes qu'il y aura un
compromis didier billion moi j'ai un
désaccord sur la question des sanctions
parce que il faut pas avoir une vision
occidentale au centre et de ce qui se
déroule aujourd'hui en amérique latine
en afrique au moyen-orient il y a eu une
majorité pour condamner l'agression
russe ça c'est un fait par contre ceux
qui véritablement aujourd'hui à petit
les sanctions ce sont les pays
occidentaux plus quelques alliés en asie
et qui sont traditionnellement des
alliés des pays occidentaux et c'est
leur choix souverain ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose
comprenons bien que cette volonté des
états unis d'affaiblir au maximum la
russie risque d'avoir une conséquence
qui est antinomique avec nous intéresse
c'est à dire de précipiter la russie
dans les bras de la chine donc comme ça
nous aurons un blog sino-russe avec le
partenaire chinois en position
clairement de domination mais ce que
c'est notre intérêt à nous de
cristalliser la chine et les hivers
depuis 2004 isaksson analyste
évidemment
j'ai pas dit qu'il ne l'était pas mais
ils attendent que la russie tombe comme
un fruit mûr de façon à pouvoir capter
un certain nombre de connaissances
technologiques de caunes que les russes
possèdent et que les chinois ne possède
pas aujourd'hui donc pour eux c'est tout
bénéfice mais évidemment ils sont
prudents parce que cette situation
induite par l'agression russe bouleverse
totalement le commerce international et
ça ça ne va pas dans le sens des
intérêts chinois donc évidemment les
choses ne sont jamais en noir et blanc
et les chinois sont effectivement très
prudent comme à leur habitude marc gasol
lettre ma région d'auray ce qu'il
paraisse qu'on parle justement à
washington de cette façon dont la chine
pourrait
utiliser finalement le conflit est
effectivement rendre presque dépendante
de son économie la russie à force
d'affaiblissement des rues ce que vient
de dire en fait didier billion
c'est en effet c'est ça fait partie du
débat le rapprochement sino russes
point d'attention majeur c'est un
rapprochement sino russe qui n'a pas
finalement je dirais besoins des
occidentaux pour opérer
il va il y aura peut-être un effet des
sanctions etc actuellement étudiée mais
il est complètement antérieur il a une
logique et
et là arrivera j'en veux dire de quoi
qu'il arrive puisqu'il ya eu la
déclaration du 4 février entre le
président poutine est présent en chie
sur sur les conséquences ce que observe
en fait les américains ici c'est
finalement l'attitude de la chine donc
vis-à-vis des sanctions puisque elle n'a
aucune envie finalement la chine de ceux
de risquer d'être elle même sous
sanction
en exportant des revenants aider la
russie est pour l'instant on ne l'a pas
vu donc il y à ce premier point le
deuxième point c'est que la chine a
beaucoup plus d'intérêt économique en
europe actuellement qu'avec la russie et
donc elle veut préserver cela et c'est
lié aux premiers points et enfin les
américains regardent enfin considèrent
qu'ils ont besoin d'être très ferme avec
la russie notamment parce que la chine
observe les réactions des occidentaux et
des etats-unis ont promis lieu pour le
cas taïwan et en tout cas beaucoup
d'experts ici américain recommande très
fortement à l'administration d'être
irréprochable dans la réponse à la
russie pour que la chine elle-même soit
convaincu que une réponse sera aussi
majeur en cas en cas d'élection de
taiwan même si il faut le rappeler ce ne
sont pas du tout les mêmes réalités
entre l'ukraine et a redonné goût et ça
pourrait être un précédent justement
véritablement cette réaction américaine
je crois qu'elle est la situation la
situation taiwan est complètement
différente je ne pense pas que les
chinois aient l'intention d'attaquer
maintenant parce qu'ils savent très bien
quelles seraient les conséquences sur
leur commerce les chinois allaient de
l'intervention possible à un moment
donné oui chine mais d'abord les
taïwanais
ont renforcé leur défense avec l'aide
des etats-unis est l'exemple ukrainien
montre quand il ya à la fois une volonté
le populaire et des armes ce après sa
sélection ce que disait marc et jourdain
en tout cas pour pour les états unis
est-ce qu'on peut tout de même
parler d'une possibilité de dialogue
elena volochine avec vladimir poutine à
bas un dialogue oui évidemment c'est
parce que d'ailleurs la finlande est les
suédois ont parlé à vladimir poutine oui
non mais le fait qu' il ya un dialogue
mais oui c'est à dire que et vladimir
poutine dit toujours qu'il est ouvert à
la discussion sergueï lavrov son
ministre des affaires étrangères dit
toujours qu'il est ouvert la discussion
les ukrainiens ont dit ça manque s'ils
étaient plus ouverts à la discussion et
que tous les pourparlers étaient
suspendus emmanuel macron se dit ouvert
à la discussion
le dialogue oui mais sauf que il y a
toujours cet espace de 2 pour parler de
dialogue on l'a vu aussi avec le
processus de minsk depuis 2014 et que la
russie a mené cette invasion du dombass
dont elle n'a jamais admis
qu'elle y prenez part et que ses armées
étaient étaient stationnés que ses
généraux étaient à la manoeuvre et ses
services secrets dans la manoeuvre dans
la création de ces républiques
populaires dans le même temps il y avait
les accords de minsk les accords de paix
ou la russie disait nous sommes
extérieur c'est une guerre civile et
cetera donc à part en fait un illustre
collègue disait on ne peut pas avoir un
débat d'idée si on n'est pas d'accord
sur les faits donc il y à il y aura
forcément un dialogue des pourparlers
sauf que sur le terrain militairement
vladimir poutine sera toujours à
chercher à
poursuivre ses objectifs quel que soit
le discours quelles que soient les
pourparlers quelles que soient les mains
tendues et au contraire quelque part les
pourparlers et les formats de dialogue
et les formats de discussions sont plus
là pour légitimer la russie lorsqu'elle
dit c'est nous avons voulu la paix ce
sont les autres qui ont fait échouer les
négociations etc c'est ce qui s'est
toujours passé jusqu'à présent
malheureusement dans ce conflit en
ukraine donc on n'y est pas dans le
dialogue non tout se décidera sur sur
sur le terrain le dira les mois qui
viennent alors un petit mot pour
conclure d'autres pays pour air
justement rejoindre l'otan alors on
parle de la suisse qui tout d'un coup
les suisses souhaiteraient avait déjà
les balkans qui sont en attente la
tendance intéressante pour ça que les
suisses peut-être qu'ils aient fui alors
la moldavie puisque la présidente
moldaves étaient aujourd'hui à paris
l'union européenne ni dans l'hostie
soldats dans une situation particulière
parce que elle a des troupes russes sur
la transnistrie il ya mille soldats
russes et si poutine veut aller
conquérir des ça il peut s'appuyer sur
ses forces qui sont en moldavie
d'ailleurs c'était un objectif militaire
au départ ça c'était c'est assez
clairement démontrée par les services
secrets par les sources paramilitaires
qu'on a pu consulter il y avait cette
volonté de créer un couloir vers la
transnistrie il ya eu quelques
provocations qui nous ont laissé penser
que peut-être ça allait être maintenant
et puis finalement non parce que c'est
toujours la même question en fait la
question est simple l'admirent poutine
at il les moyens militaires de saison du
jeune père sont énormes didier billion
et elle pourra être vôtre demander une
adhésion à l'otan de la moelle d'un
point de vue de la moldavie il demander
l'adhésion à l'union européenne sans
pareil qui se déroule sur la
transnistrie quant à la suisse je vois
c'est avec un peu plus de recul je pense
que c'est un effet médiatique actuel
vous êtes sûr parce que manifestement
dans les sondages tous les suspects les
suisses les des raisons ils ont acceptés
s'ils ont également adhéré au sein de la
russie sur les hommes je pense que le
résultat serait sûrement négatives et
les suisses ont beaucoup à se faire
pardonner
sur les trafics y compris avec les
oligarques en temps et donc ils ont tout
à fait intérêt redit suisse réalise avec
émotion à ce qui se passe c'est de
l'émotion ce n'est pas de la stratégie
tout cas ce n'est pas une volonté
d'ailleurs c'est comme c'est comme les
anglais qui est qui et qui font beaucoup
de bruit mais les anglais avaient à
londres london grade et tous les
oligarques avec un statut spécial
l'aborigène s'en est allé voir les
suédois les
les finlandais pour leur dire qu'ils
allaient leur garantir justement une
aide militaire merci en tout cas le fait
d'avoir été avec nous donc affaire à
suivre puisque le sommet de l'otan s'est
fin juin n'est ce pas à madrid donc on
sera effectivement si ils entrent
effectivement dans l'otan la finlande et
la suède mais
revenons à jeudi et si le temps reste
une alliance défensive
consacré à l'europe aussi c'est une otan
mondialisé et voilà effectivement le
débat stratégique au sein de l'alliance
benoît d'aboville merci beaucoup merci
didier billion merci elena rébéna
volochine merci à vous marie jourdain
vous étiez avec nous en direct de
washington
merci à vous tous nous avoir suivis et
reste avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]